可得要聊聊怎么学习吧
好多人是不会学习的
而且很努力
阿姨很够哭
看了好多书
对吧
生活没改变
为什么呢
砸血呢
对吧
首先第一个就是
你的
一定要向
施学习
就向地开的学习
不要老跟参加冒学习对吧
大家听过
那个我们就
赵老鼠话猫
是吧你赵老三娘猫
你有话啥话老鼠啊对吧
所以输入的质量非常重要
就跟大施学就是你知识的密度深度
你这实用场景是完全不一样的
所以
首先第一个就是你的新学院
第二个的话呢我发现很认识学东西的方式也不对
我玩好多人就是比如说看数
中头看到我
从头看到我
然后画界
然后
一个关键资
看看看半天
到底该怎么学
学三个东西
第一个学什么呢学
结构
学他的CD图他又怎么思考的
他的框架结构
第二个的话呢
停电他的
工具
似于模型
第二个是工具
工具箱他的似于模型
有那些方法怎么就有问题的
第三个学他的表达
到底怎么表达的
就我们学东西基本上从这三个
方式来来做然后以后会有细节
那真正学的时候也不是随便学的好的说
活得不得推荐一本书吧不是这样的不是说这个人的书力还你就要去学的
对不对
那之前就有人问说活得不得你为什么不够我们介绍一些
就是国学的时候
我说你给我推荐一些国学的时候什么时候什么道德经
我说我不配毒
我不配毒你能不能贸易怎么
我现在用不上了
对吧
现在用不上
我觉得可能在年大一点要学所以我说第一个就是
你要知道你要学什么不是别人跟你推荐啥你就学
所以第一个就是你要知道你要学啥我个人会学那种被你压的
比如说我在日上公共的那种要学
学的观众我发现有人做的比我好被你压了对吧人家似于模型比我厉害
人家的表达比我厉害
人家就有问题的能力比我厉害还被你压了
你找到这个人
想的学习就好准
特别害怕丢蠢
哎呀我不能丢过人啊
结果结果还是个小克拉密对吧
丢过人怕什么呢对吧丢啊人进行忘了对吧我以前是念进行
对吧我我回来做机了对吧我回来下一个啥呀
水垮就是能凡是能力更厉害了对吧
就不断进化所以第一个就是
少你毁年压的点的静化公共被压取了一点然后跟人休息第二个就是
你要学什么
调求社群的大変
比如说我学生活群 我学谁呢
我学 我学可能蛮歌
我学精灭了比我达
我可能学纳巴尔
对吧 我学我怎么办更好的
就是让人更喜欢的去听
对吧 我可能去学卡林
所以你要有一个技能的一个很军的技能
我要学什么东西
找哪个大师
然后跟他学学什么
解决什么问题
你应该有一个
所以第二不应该有个大师
所以对吧
然后第三步才是参业大师
这个地方很重要了
怎么参业大师
首先第一个不应该
我说拆结构
什么拆结构
我发现就是我跟达说的
很多人都说充头到位度
话句子不是这样的
读东西首先看结构
我给大家久了一子
比如说我看达文儿
学达文儿我给大家一个建议
我只要有一本说达文儿保典
也说我经常推荐给大家的
其实我个人问你要学达文儿
你去找达文儿的不客
先看达文儿的一篇文章叫如何支付
我为什么这么推荐你呢
因为达文儿那本说做者不是达文儿
是有人把达文儿战亡上的推文总结整理出来的
所以那个这本说其实不是达文儿写的
话是达文儿的
但是达文儿似就不客
有一篇文章叫如何支付
那是达文儿写的
所以你打开
你看我为什么要说看达文文
打开你打开看
他会有一个结构
比如说他一上来
叫追求财富
而不是金钱和地位
为世界创造富族
私优市厂市人类的内在本质
你看前三段的讲什么
他来讲世界文
才来讲世界文儿
原来他一上来讲的世界文
私优市厂
所以你要学自由市厂
你看
这就是你学的结构
然后赚钱不是靠运气
然后运气成为你的命运
讲什么
讲的概率
然后再往下他的思想
所以首先你要看这个人的表达的结构是什么
对吧
而不是运上来就进入细节
你哪些有个框架
所以读书是这么多的
第二个的话
就是你要学他的工具
什么工具
就是一个人体球问题的工具
他思念我行
对吧
比如说很多人说
这个盲格很厉害
那你怎么读
你比如说穷叉里高点
那边手就很好
他里面要打了那个演讲
其中比如说
给他决定一样
他在哈法大决的演讲
那你看学他的结
他学的工具怎么学的
我给他读其中一段
他说这样
他说你看他上了演讲的时候这么说的
他说我比卡森严讲的时候
所以说呢
我失败的次数更多
痛苦更多
痛苦的方式也更多
我显然有次数进一步发
会卡森的主题
所以我决定给大家讲一讲
怎么失败
然后他列出了个清单
我这个好厉害
对了什么
这叫印象思维表达吗
对不对
所以你看一上来就告诉你
我不告诉你如何称谋
我告诉你如何失败
然后我那个失败清单
然后本来告诉你
成功的方法就是渐少失败
对不对
那你看你希望那后就有这么用
印象思维中表达
先印象思维
然后在列轻单
这是盲格的比行的方法
对吧
那我可以怎么用
比如说有人上
有人切我去演讲
说胡子哥
你来跟我们家样
思维体怎么做吧
我不是一上来给大家春又逼
我给大家讲讲
怎么有上千万的播放量
下面我能那个对你
你每条什么都上千万吧
你不能这么讲
你说我给大家讲一讲
怎么失败的经历
你就知道我做了好多失败的像
你看
就是我这方法有经历
比如说拍标市民
怎么没有播放量
拍标市民
怎么没有关注
我给大家讲讲
怎么才能做到
没有关注
没有播放量
你看列了一类清单
然后我给大家讲
其实我也做过一些
更失败的那种
就是偶尔有落网之余
怕了个
就是上千万条播放的
好几号变成了
我给大家总结一下
我是怎么失败的
怎么落网之余的
列出来
你看
这种表达方式
这种结构中工具
特别受欢迎
那你不会有反感
一上来
我将我失败吧
然后有感觉过
对吧
就是印象思为表达
加列清单
这是非常好的方法
工具吗
所以你看别人
别人的工具
什么呀
英国关系什么呀
结构是什么呀
这个你看
第三个部分就是
学什么学的表达方式
有什么事表达方式呢
对吧
有一个人的表达
比如说看
卡林的表达
对吧
怎么让别人更清楚
更好
你比如说像
像拿玩的表达
就非常简击
财富不是钱
财富是什么
财富是一套
自我运转的系统
你看他的结构
就是什么东西
先找到你们一个基本认知
然后打责他
财富不是钱
你不是因为之前
而是什么
大和认知
老家
这就是一个很好的表达
所以我们去看一些人
他做的表达
比较好
你把他财富
偶尔人家是怎么
怎么做的
比较好的表达的
把那个结构
去联系出来
所以我刚才说的
你三部还记得吗
对吧
首先你要联什么能力
第二
这个能力向谁学你有个所影
第三
你去学这个人的时候
你猜三个东西
可不是财
可不是随便开于又化
财结构
财工具
财表达
然后
第四五
每天
每天花时间
你不要看那么多
可能开一段
五百次八万次
找到中间
对吧
你往下看
这段内容你要深入的去理解了
怎么理解
这个问题
我要理解了
我怎么理解
我先反向表达
这个
他这个一定成立吗
有没有不可
有没有可能他不成立
他的预设条件是什么
把它列出来
然后翻转过来
这个结构是什么
就像
就像芒哥的你像思维一样
第二部分练经历
对吧
比如说
我能不能像达瓦儿一样
把一句话经历成
十个次导二十个次之间
我就联系
对不对
第三个
就是我们能不能翻转呢
他不是什么
而是什么
对吧
或者你从谁呢
获得一个关注说
怎么讲故事
英雄之旅
我怎么讲故事
获得是怎么600
我给大家分享
才大事
应该怎么才
停队一下
让用或脑补
所以每天去学这么一点
每天从大事人上
学得这么一段方法
然后用在自己身上
就是工具箱
你每天都在进步
一个计刀一个计刀一个计刀
一张手好几个工具箱
对吧
然后每周的话
最好完整的猜一个人
完整的猜一个大事
对吧
他的结构
他的表达结构
是应用这里模式吗
还是耐课模型
对吧
还是什么
SQA模式
结构
猜他都工具
他有哪些工具
是结局什么样的问题
这个工具
他是怎么用的
他是怎么标达的
然后每天
然后每天可以联系
所以我给大家讲
就是学东西一定要像大事学习
对吧
就是从他身上学到一些
东西你的事上的深度啊
你的密度啊
你就问的方法都不太一样
那么怎么猜啊
首先你要去拆
你要去拆节
拆节怎么猜
各位三块儿哦
第一个就是他的结构
第二个就是他的工具
第三个就是他的表达
然后你要去干嘛
你要去时间啊
然后你要去拆一点习啊
然后才把它应用在不同的场景里